o pessoal de 20 e hoje vou ensinar como
fazer um helicóptero e com vocês podem
ver este encontro foi feito usando uma
garrafa o fim de picolé cola uma bateria
do novo voltas2 motorzinhos e pronto
mas algumas coisas que vocês vão ver ao
longo do futuro real
a tripulação prontas lhe ensinar uma
tripulação ficava muito banho tínhamos
brinquedos e tal ea tripulação decidiu
também ficar muito bem ali um canhão ali
à frente e como vocês podem ver é
funcional
esta coisa que vou inventar agora que é
usada nas festas é vocês têm ter mais de
18 anos para poderem comprar quando fui
comprar perguntaram pelo meu cartão do
cidadão é e só comprova que os uma
pessoa que aparenta ser bastante bem
aí eu já não sei fazer e cortei a
partida também é com rosca
escutei garrafão banho e nem estas
partículas não ficaram muito bem e fui
sculley vários pontinhos para fazer uma
chapa para que a garrafa não é daquelas
donda cef maio retangular e eu falei um
pouco disso só porque eu não tô com o
tempo é e podia deixar o seu vídeo sem
comentário mas eu prometo fazer assim
apressa para não desiludir alguns sons
que podem sempre com comentários e vai
gentil usar aquela chapa para tapar esta
parte da guerra rafa e hoje ainda vamos
fazer mais um vídeo é que vou deixar
pronto para posterior depois porque eu
vou ficar uma semana fora é em proteína
e deixar tudo feito foi uma coisa assim
mas à última da hora já que o corpo aí
aponta de quatro pontinhos e wu por cole
e vejam como e com qual ficará se
inclinado em direção àquela parte
central do campus a cair e colando os
quatro pontinhos e isso vai dar uma
grande resistência a cauda
estou sacola quinto mas vocês quiserem
podem usar outra coisa qualquer e aí
podem usar aquela escolares também
funciona só que demora mais tempo
agora não sabe cortar produzimos este
pudesse tinham entre 13 e 14 centímetros
mas - vejam que eu fiz duas linhas são
iguais nos dois pombinhos e é lá que eu
vou colar que os cursinhos
vejam que faz 90 graus com aquela parte
verde
depois é só colar um helicóptero é
inclinado e fica melhor ea garrafa
também ajudava porque estava do lado
sempre assim na final a garrafa era bem
cuidada 88 e aqui fica muito bem depois
na mesa o city o plano vocês puserem
para criar um contato para a bateria de
nove voltas
é só deixar o outro novo volte que já
não tenha carga e varjão como em caixa
eu vou tirar um todo de dvds players mas
se vocês não tiverem podem usar de
brinquedos velhos que prontos
é só ir lá e buscar o que pode acontecer
e elas serem maiores mas aí é só vocês
ajustarem a estrutura limpo que dinho
que funciona também agora vou pôr os
cabos nos motores
é isso que são bastante simples e só tem
um cabo mesmo não sou daquelas tem
vários cabos lá dentro
stern também estão melhores do que elas
têm vários elementos de cobre
acham que eu tenho pai extremidades e
vou colar o primeiro motor em cima sim
mas enfrenta usado depois o outro motor
li na parte de trás responder se um
pouco os cabos e para juntar no
balanceamento além do helicóptero foi
uma pilha alioune elemento ainda mais
para frente ok vocês vão ver daqui um
pouco que a cauda ficou muito pesada
nem percebo nada mas é por ser um
sistema da lan wan kuok agora você está
em conectar os cabos dos pouso num carro
do primeiro motor e do segundo no mesmo
pólo e outro e outro do cantor é no
outro pólo aqui e depois vocês têm que
ver para que lado é que vocês querem que
as vossas ela exigirem caso vocês não
gostam de uma rotação do meirelles é só
em fronteira popularidade cair depois
aquela a china ea frança entrou e cópia
ficado estável porque eu fiquei assim
pra cima da cauda
estou fazendo agora uma coisa com uma
tampa
veja aqui como ela ficou para fazer é
luiz grande o helicóptero
o sofá do outro lado também vai
justificar se com uma inclinação e mesmo
com mazelas e para tapar aquela partida
assim my fire da conexão eu usei outra
tampa
vejam que eu tirei aquela parte que fica
assim por cima né ficando só particular
o colégio já está e para que as partes
ficarem maiores é para da cela e
acrescentar um palito grande cada lado
tipo de som que elas por ser fiel
nós vendemos também com ao pé deste
cliente acessa por cola e encaixar lá a
eu fiz um furo naquela para pequenina
ficou-lhe com cola nelas
e se é para ajudar a conectar melhor que
entra a cola dentro do furo e depois
ficar muito mais forte ligação de cinema
um pontinho em pina para trás mas vocês
tenham cuidado com o tamanho desses
políticos para não ser muito grande e
bater cuco com elas grande que só vocês
têm que ver em tamanho antes e agora vou
fazer as aberturas é opcional e acho que
eu também muito bonito assim sem nada na
minha tripulação e de fazer a abertura e
fez um furo e passar um fio preconceito
por eles pararam o caminhão saía base
e depois ele fez o trabalho para
conseguir um terreno pois aquelas coisas
das festas que não sei como funciona a
estamos quase no fim no final sol e foi
assim um pouco improvisado assim muito
rápido é porque não queria deixar está
em comentário mas também não tem tempo
pra fazer como fazer para o grêmio é
porque tira mesmo muito tempo é e ainda
tem que fazer outro vídeo fiz um projeto
excelente mesmo uma caçadeira de dois
canos que dispara muito banho de sol
eu vou já editaram em seguida banho
rápido e fazer talvez um comentário sem
tamanho provavelmente não vai dar tempo
mas não vou ficar sem vídeos
nesta e na próxima chegamos ao fim eu
espero que tenham gostado espero que me
perdoem mas vão ter um província tanque
para um sítio é estranho obrigado até a
próxima